I don't always have time for a luxurious bath time,
but whenever I get the chance,
I'm always reaching for my Old Whaling Company products.
This is a local Charleston based company,
and they have the most delicious smelling
coastal inspired scents for all of their products, bathrooms,
soaps, and lotions.
I just got an order in of their Floral Coast scent,
which is like hydrangeas at the beach.
And the best part for y'all
is that they just opened up their TikTok shop
so you can get this bundle,
this three pack of goodies,
sent to your house,
and you don't have to come all the way to Charleston.
They have tons of different scents,
so if Floral Coast isn't your jam,
you can go try something else.
However, this is my favorite.
So I'm gonna go ahead and link this bundle down here
for their TikTok shop so you can try all three products.
And especially, don't forget the body butter. Your skin will thank me.